[Music]
it's beginning to look a lot like
Christmas while some people are decking
the halls kids are forgetting that they
better not pout and better not cry
especially when it comes to meeting
Santa Claus there are some pretty
hilarious moments of frightened kids
squirming from Santa's lap watch until
the end of the video to see how one
little girl's gesture has everyone
shocked and dying with laughter if you
love Christmas as much as we do make
sure to subscribe to the things to see
other videos like these today we're
showing you 20 priceless pictures of
kids meeting Santa that will make you
laugh too much to handle this one cracks
us up for so many reasons it's
impossible not to take a second look
when seeing this picture first of all
Santa's little visitor has hilariously
taken over his special seat this guy has
his own idea of what it means to visit
Santa and it does not involve sitting on
his lap normally kids share their wish
list with Santa hoping they've behaved
well enough to deserve every item they
ask for this child doesn't seem to have
any intention of sharing his desires in
fact he doesn't even want to hear
anything as he's tightly covering his
ears holding his head in his hands his
face is just hilarious it looks like
he's really had enough of all these
holiday visits and just can't take it
anymore we love how Santa is admiring
this cutie and his unusual yet amazingly
accurate facial expression shot or Santa
even Jimmy Kimmel and guest host Neil
Patrick Harris got on board with the
annual Santa meltdown trend the show has
a segment dedicated to showing kids
faces and determining whether they're
getting a flu shot or sitting in Santa's
lap the results it turns out it's
practically impossible to distinguish
between the fearful expressions of kids
about to get a shot and those who
finally get to sit on Santa's lap after
waiting through a mall Santa lineup it
seems that parents are getting a laugh
while their children react and complete
fear after meeting the one and only
Santa Claus it's surprising how hard it
is to tell the difference between a shot
and Santa double trouble although Santa
wears glasses he can't believe his eyes
just Santa's wide-eyed facial expression
in this
is enough to get us giggling these girls
look exactly identical especially when
they're both crying their eyes out on
Santa's lap we imagine that this Santa
has never had to hold two screaming
children at once and it's written all
over his bewildered babe keeping his
hands full these girls are screaming for
help and are clearly terrified research
has shown that babies and especially
twins cry as an indica munich ating
their needs to one another these girls
are definitely on the same page when it
comes to wanting to break free from
Santa bigbrother problems having a first
Christmas with a baby sister sounds like
an adorable setup for a Santa photo as
any older sibling will tell you nothing
is predictable with a baby around
no matter the intention and how sweet a
new family looks together holding back
tears are not part of a baby's plans
especially not this one what we love
most about this holiday pick is the big
brothers cringe face looks like having a
new member in the family can take some
getting used to
there is something about his frown that
communicates how unfortunate the event
is although this family had planned for
a sweet photo they ended up with a snap
shot of a big brother just getting used
to putting up with his little sister
quick while he's not looking this next
one has us cracking up a boy and a girl
are seem to be visibly struggling to
free themselves from Santa's hold
meanwhile our man dressed in red is
trying to think of his happy place a
workshop full of fuzzy elves we would
think that Santa is one person who would
be sympathetic to the distraught cries
of the children he accidentally scares
our favorite part about this pic is the
fact that Santa's eyes are hidden behind
a set of cotton white bangs the saying
is out of sight out of mind and it seems
that this Santa is trying to wish
himself away from his seat even the
little girl's bow suggests the
picture-perfect scene without a smile in
sight this picture is sure to bring the
family some laughter over the holiday
season you scream I scream there's
something about this next pic that
provides a heartwarming chuckle despite
the red bike set up in the corner of the
frame this boy's face is not the one you
expect to see rushing to gifts on
Christmas morning though he may be
dressed for the season
this little boy clearly wants out not
even propped on Santa's lap we love that
the photographer still captured a moment
that displays both Santa and his visitor
in a helpless cry mouth open and tears
streaming down his face this boy has no
intention of whispering his wish list
into Santa's ear Santa isn't doing any
whispering either as he is seen in the
background laughs empty screaming in
unison this Santa is making us laugh
with his uncharacteristic facial
expression we can't help but relate to
seriously disturbed there's something
about a baby making a serious face which
is always irresistible being introduced
to someone for the first time could be
awkward for many of us this baby
definitely understands the social
pressures that go into an introduction
and he's not taking it lightly this
little man is so professionally decked
in a Christmas vest and his expression
is as serious as his outfit well we
imagine kids being excited to eat Santa
Claus this little guy seems like he's
still trying to make up his mind about
the man whose lap he's been put on it
even looks like he's suspicious of who
this new bearded acquaintances may be
he's even deciding if he should trust
him with his wishlist
wake me when it's over one thing we
often forget to account for over the
holidays is that so much of our planning
can go awry
we may hope that once dressed in a cute
Christmas sweater and having survived
the mall lino kids will be excited and
ready to smile for their annual photo on
Santa's lap the only thing that can be
expected is the unexpected and this baby
definitely caught his parents and Santa
off-guard finally getting to Santa's lap
was exhausting for this cutie who is
fast asleep in Santa's arms the best
part of the photo is that Santa was
ready for anything even an unexpected
naptime in the photo
Santa is reminding us to keep quiet
something we usually wouldn't associate
with holiday cheer I did not sign up for
this most of the photos on this list
involves such funny faces we helped but
guess what children are trying to say in
this case we know exactly what this
little boy is saying because he had been
taught sign language this little guy is
trying to sign help to his parents he
wants to get out of there as soon as
possible and his horrified look combined
with the sign language for help is
hilarious now at the team Spencer has
spoken out on Twitter and identified
himself as the baby who signed for help
while on Santa's lap sticking his tongue
out and communicating his fear is so
adorable and even Santa got a good laugh
out of it who are you we have included
sleeping babies on our list but this one
is a laugh out loud shot we're assuming
it was taken at the baby woke up only to
find themselves being held by a stranger
being held by anyone other than mom and
dad can be a scary experience but waking
up in such a surreal place definitely
got this baby to react the present Santa
is offering the baby does not even seem
to be distracting the child whose face
is the picture of horror meltdowns go
viral this next one is a great example
of using talent to turn lemons in
photographer Jeff Rothman realized that
many of the photos he took of children
with Santa Claus resulted in a tearful
disaster rather than getting rid of the
evidence
Rothman stored them and posted them
online as a collection he titled the
naughty list
using something that went so wrong was
the right move Rahman received up to
four million clicks on his photos like
this one a blonde baby rushing to escape
the equally distraught Santa behind her
this photo went viral parents could
totally relate to Santa's frustration
wait until you see our number1 photo and
why some might even be offended by it
satanic Santa we couldn't leave this one
off our list especially with the
popularity of Stephen King's it this
picture features a balloon albeit a blue
rather than red balloon but Santa is
definitely making his best Pennywise
smile the best part of this photo is the
girl on his left knee struggling so much
to break free that you can see her
diaper instead of laughing it off this
Santa has had enough and looks like he's
ready to head back to the North Pole
it's clear that Santa has had enough of
the fuss but he's not doing a very good
job at hiding it Santa's screaming elf
this little girl screaming her head off
on Santa's lap maybe in the cutest
outfit we've seen on this list this poor
Santa and the Alps big sister are doing
all they can to keep up the mood but an
adorable screaming baby no matter the
role they're meant to play is definitely
hard to ignore the pose outfits an
unmistakable embarrassment on a big
sister space is what gets this photo
included on our list nap time
this Santa was visited by a teeny tiny
version of himself any parent will tell
you that it is not wise to wake a
sleeping baby the precious moments of
silence and the peaceful look of a baby
asleep is among the happiest moments
these parents and this Santa knew better
than to wake up to Santa disguised
newborn even Santa took advantage of
this quiet time to catch up on some
much-needed rest
parents need a break from their crying
babies but Santa must also desperately
want a moment of silence when having to
pose with so many unwilling and
terrified children this one is funny
because Santa is asleep making him an
identical grown-up version of the
sleeping baby on his lap battle of the
sexes this photo is just too good well a
big family can beat a otic and noisy
this picture shows that we can all still
make the best of it did you notice
something about who is smiling and who
is in full-fledged meltdown mode it
seems that someone forgot to tell the
girls in this picture that Santa was
coming to town well the two little boys
and Santa are enjoying a hearty laugh
the two sisters decked with bows on
their heads are not feeling the
Christmas spirit sometimes when things
don't go as planned we can choose
between frying or laughing it seems that
the guys in this photo went with
laughing over crying it is the best
medicine after all fake out the best
thing about childhood is the use of
imagination to turn an ordinary activity
into an amazing adventure sometimes
imagination gets the best of us in the
worst ways and that's definitely what
happened in this photo of kids needing
Santa sitting in front of the fireplace
these cuties encounter a Santa
decoration to them the Santa real or
fake is the scariest sight instead of
spreading the joy with Christmas
decorations it looks like this
ornamental Santa is spreading the fear
the Santa may be fake but the fear is
real if it doesn't even take a real life
breathing Santa to terrify this young
child Christmas shopping disaster it's a
bit hard to imagine how this photo came
to be instead of opting for the usual
seat atop Santa's lap these kids went
with a much less conventional option
Santa who had to stand to be seen in the
photo is crouched behind a shopping cart
filled with both a sleeping and
screaming child killing two birds with
one stone is a helpful time saver and
sometimes essential during the busy
holiday season these parents were
strategic in thinking they could easily
use their shopping cart as a mode of
transportation gliding their kids in and
out of the Christmas photograph
sometimes despite our best efforts
unforeseen
issues may arise and make for a
hilarious memory family feud this
picture is surprisingly the only one on
our list where a parent had to get
involved and join in on the photo the
holidays bring tons of laughter and fun
but they can also cause some family
disputes it seems that for this family
meeting Santa was definitely enough to
cause a breakdown even mom has her eyes
closed like her three boys everyone is
screaming and laughing at the disaster
that became of this special experience
mom is in the photo to try to keep her
kids in place and even she is struggling
Santa however seems thrilled to accept
the help one boy in front can't quite
make it to Santa but he doesn't seem to
want to he's trying to split as fast as
possible peekaboo
this photo is as confusing and unusual
as it is hysterical many of the photos
on our list show that getting into
Santa's lap is not always what kids want
when they first meet him this baby
somehow found his way on top of Santa's
seat and he's still far from pleased
Santa on the other hand looked as though
he is sick of chasing babies and getting
them to pose for a photo instead he
sighs and waits for the photographer to
snap the pick this baby probably held by
a parent is unhappy but being above and
behind Santa's chair is so strange
we can't help but crack up popping up
out of nowhere this baby is ready to pop
up and away flipping out this little
girl had us and the internet in stitches
her unusual pose and her sisters
reaction is what makes this our number
one photo unlike most of the kids on our
list this little girl wanted to speak to
Santa about a scrape on her finger when
her parents asked to see it too she
turned middle finger in the air to
display her tiny injury a hilarious shot
of a sweet blonde girl sitting on
Santa's lap and the middle finger raised
high in the air
adding to the hilarity as the sneaky
smile on her sister's face Santa has his
work cut out for him as this photo looks
like naughty and nice paid him a visit
which picture on our list made you laugh
the most let us know in the comments and
that's it for twenty priceless pictures
of kids meeting Santa that will make you
laugh if you want to see more stories
like this make sure to check out twenty
most hilarious kid Christmas wishes that
may
even Santa laughs thanks for watching
[Music]